hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about constipation okay
now number one you need about four to
five pounds of friendly microbes in your
digestive system that do 90% of the
digestion okay so that's most of you the
great majority of your digestion happens
in the small intestine alright and
that's from all the friendly bacteria
that are there to help you break things
down if you history of antibiotics that
eating you probably don't have this even
if you have constipation you probably
don't have them so that's the most
likely cause of constipation there's a
lot of probiotics people take let me
just tell you why I use the liquid
probiotics and this is a different type
of probiotic because it's called a
effector of microbes which is a
combination of three different
combinations of synergistic microbes
that work together to actually have you
a lot more spectrum of different types
of microbes it's called live probiotic
flora you just take a cap of this before
you go to bed okay and then all night
long it grows it grows through your body
and you wake up and it's your stomach is
feeling a lot less bloated okay so
that's a real good thing to reestablish
your microbes and I recommend taking
that probably for a month or so and then
don't take it for a month and then take
it for a month go on and off because
there's going to be a point where your
body's like okay I had enough I have
enough microbes okay it's not going to
hurt you to take more but it's a really
good thing to just fortify you alright
so and you'll notice that your breath in
the morning won't be bad your stool
won't be as have bad odor it's really
interesting okay so number two bile
what's bile bi le bile is made by liver
stored in the gall bladder and helps you
break down fats it's kind of like the
detergent that dissolves the grease it's
in the bits in the gallbladder formula
simply because I wanted to give a
solution to people without in a bile
especially if you don't have a gall
bladder especially if it's a sluggish
gall bladder
especially if you have stress or high
estrogen from a pregnancy that's why you
get nauseated that's
kobol like kobol creates bloating right
shoulder pain headaches and constipation
because bile is a lubricant so again if
your problem is more of a lack of bile
the simple addition the bile will boom
pop it in there and you'll start to
start eliminating immediately so this is
a no-brainer and again your body needs a
healthy bile but it can run out and
become sluggish if you don't have a gall
bladder and bile is recycled so you just
might need a little kick starter so you
can then start recycling bile okay very
important and then acid acid
I use the betaine hydrochloride from the
outside of vinegar plus so it has the
plus of the betaine hydrochloride and
then we have apple cider vinegar
concentrates a couple leaves before a
meal and the only reason I would take
that is if I had like indigestion or
heartburn something like that because if
you're not digesting at the stomach
level the cycle of digestion will end up
down here as undigested food so the food
just sits there because you're not
breaking down the stomach level so you
have all these this chain reaction that
start to the stomach where you start to
break down food and you just have to
isolate what part of this cycle is it
broken okay
is it the stomach is the gallbladder is
it the small intestine and you just have
to go by symptoms all right so so you
might want to add a little stomach a
stomach acid and boom it just handles
right there I want to talk about fiber
for a second because sometimes people
think that you're taking Metamucil or a
fiber or brand thinking that that's a
thing that is pushing things through
it's not like that fiber is not the
thing that pushes anything fiber is
there as food for your microbes that's
what it does but what there's a
differentiated type of fiber from grain
versus vegetable fiber I like to add
vegetable fiber because you get actual
nutrients from that the fiber from grain
brand Metamucil has no nutrition so
really it's not the best type of fiber
you need so you want to have vegetables
make sure that vegetable doesn't
overwhelm your microbes in bloat you
even more like if you're doing too much
kale or something like that but you want
to get your fiber from the vegetable
that's what you do so these are the four
things that will handle constipation in
the process of handling it in correcting
it you may need an herbal laxative so
find something that you you feel
comfortable with and start taking that
as a coping mechanism but this is more
of a corrective mechanism all right I'll
see you in the next video